llyod lavabre bonjour vous êtes vous
êtes donc le fermier général
de cet endroit parce qu'on est à la
ferme de bel ébat
il y en a quelques-uns notamment en ile
de france et quelques quelques lieux
même assez prestigieux effectivement
mais tout s'explique le théâtre des
billes en cours est installé
effectivement dans une ancienne ferme
mais c'est pour ça que ça regardez le
terme alors on y bel ébat pas ce qu'il
s'est passé des choses un peu âgées olé
olé non nous on ne sait pas ça reste un
secret le nom de bel ébat apparaît dès
le xvième siècle associé à associer à la
ferme sur guyancourt voilà donc mais
c'est vrai que ce nom prête à beaucoup
et on cotation qui me dérange c'est la
liberté exactement ça fait quoi trois
ans que vous êtes vous êtes ici voilà
moi ça fait trois ans
c'est quoi alors quand vous êtes arrivé
qu'est-ce que vous connaissiez de ce
lieu est qu'est-ce que vous voudrions
faire il y avait une une quelque chose à
continuer ou est-ce que vous vous
fallait amener d d d une une ligne
nouvelle dans la programmation au nom
mon projet s'inscrit dans la continuité
de celui de mon prédécesseur qui était
laurent flammarion et qui est celui qui
a ouvert le lieu il a été le premier
directeur donc avant moi et c'était un
projet axé sur l'écriture contemporaine
donc mon projet s'inscrit vraiment dans
cette continuité c'est un théâtre c'est
assez rare
non je ne peux pas dire que c'est rare
mais ces autres cas
assez agréable voilà d'arriver dans un
théâtre qui jouit déjà d'une très belle
réputation donc il n'y a absolument
aucune nécessité surtout à rompre avec
quoi que ce soit mais un plaisir de
bénéficier de cet héritage et puis bien
sûr ça ait voulu quand même bien sûr
bien sûr la même chose mais là il ya un
mot qui est important vous l'avez
prononcé il ya deux mots qui sont
importants secrétaires et contemporain
comment c'est peut-être par le premier
écriture les mots c'est quelque chose
d'important ici oui on est dans une
terre de poésie on a pour voisin la
maison de la poésie on a eu à guyancourt
pendant longtemps pour mr impôts est
donc effectivement il ya un attachement
à l'écrit mais l'écriture ça peut aussi
être l'écriture chorégraphique ou
musicale par mon dieu mais
on est attaché effectivement à la ferme
de bel ébat c'est un répertoire de la
création écrite alors contemporain tout
ça c'est très important aussi parce que
vous louez à la création actuelle quoi
oui tout à fait c'est une forte une très
forte dominante je pense que sur 60
spectacles on doit avoir à peu près 55
56 spectacle de répertoire contemporain
lieu un lieu donc vraiment tournés vers
vers son temps comment on fait pour ça
on pourra tirer les auteurs au les
auteurs et il ya les autorisons reason
is me contente sylvaine facilement un
nouveau décret rouler avec eux mais
d'abord je veux dire is vous recevez
quoi vous recevez des projets les pièces
d or soit beaucoup de projets on va
aussi on cherchait ouais il suffit pas
parfois d'attendre ce qu'on a ça on en
reçoit beaucoup on en voit beaucoup
je dirais sur une année un programme un
directeur programmateur voit peut-être
entre 150 et 200 spectacles 1 puis on en
garde entre quarante sept années 60
c'est un peu exceptionnel cette année un
oui c'est lié au fait qu'on a situé 4
journées dédiées chacune à une
discipline donc le cirque le conte la
poésie et la marionnette et au sein de
ces journées il ya cinq à six spectacles
qui sont des petites formes alors donc
ça ça donne ce chiffre impressionnant de
60 ça tourne normalement plus autour
d'une quarantaine d'ailleurs tous sont
pas de la même longueur non du tout
mais j'aime bien quand même cette
création contemporaine
bon c'est quelque chose évidemment
nécessaire on a l'impression comme ça
que les lieux d intro il ya le il des
choses classiques certains disent voilà
on n'a jamais rien fait de mieux depuis
que des gens sont morts trop c'est vrai
il ya ya ya ya cette tendance la dent
mais alors on renie pas non plus les
classiques c'est important on en a
quelques-uns on y tient beaucoup à ce
que ça fonctionne un peu comme des
repaires dans la programmation donc
voilà on a régulièrement quand même des
pièces de tchekhov de shakespeare de
molière de racine et on y prend on y
prend un très grand plaisir ce sont très
très belles pièces mais voilà il ya
cette nécessité d'accompagner aussi ceux
qui seront les classiques de demain une
certaine manière est d'essayer de
chercher voilà les les écritures les
plus belles qu'on puisse trouver
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il fait ne ré
contemporaine parce qu'elle est écrite
aujourd'hui mais qu'est-ce qui est ce qu
est ce qu il ya quelque chose qui se dit
aujourd'hui enfin qui se dit de la
société dans laquelle on vit oui
forcément le toutou théâtre se nourrit
de l'air de son temps on dit que le
théâtre est le miroir du monde donc
voilà aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on voit
beaucoup d'oeuvres interrogé le la
société marchande le libéralisme le
monde du travail beaucoup de pièces se
penche sur le monde du travail déjà
c'est nouveau
longtemps il a
aujourd'hui des auteurs devenus
classiques se sont intéressés au
commerce et au travail notamment en
bertold brecht mais aujourd'hui c'est
une forte dominante voilà on voit où
j'ai vu il n'ya pas très longtemps la
grande et fabuleuse histoire du commerce
de joël pommerat par exemple a beaucoup
d'auteurs et non des moindres
effectivement s'intéresse à la
mondialisation aussi c'est forcément le
débat devient questionner un petit peu
tout et c'est tout le sens du théâtre
contemporain c'est à dire un théâtre qui
va interroger son époque pas
nécessairement pour apporter des
réponses mais pour essayer de poser les
bonnes questions c'est quand même aussi
un défi d'attirer du public parler de
tchekhov de volière à bursa il ya des
pistes mais c'est plus facile d attirer
peut-être avec sac à main d oeuvre de
gens qui ne connaissent pas d'autres
montants pas entendu parler ah c'est sûr
que quand connaît ni l'auteur ni le
metteur en scène et les comédiens
quelque part c'est un petit peu un pari
un ça nécessite du travail de terrain
donc l'équipe de la ferme de belles et
bae est investi sur le territoire il ya
beaucoup d'ateliers
beaucoup de moyens d'approcher les gens
et puis de temps en temps même des
manières un petit peu nouvelles de
procéder je pense par exemple depuis
trois ans on a initié des ateliers de
redynamisation pour chômeurs de longue
durée d'accord c'est de manière un peu
particulière de faire du théâtre d'aller
vers des gens de leur montrer que le
théâtre est un outil un outil qui peut
être à leur service et évidemment tout
ça contribue aussi un élargissement du
public et à ce qu'on appelle la
démocratisation
parfois du public mais cette importance
sociale d'enfin gardant une dimension
citoyenne entre oui oui bien sûr bien
sûr c'est important le théâtre doit doit
être inscrit vraiment au coeur de la
ville moi j'ai envie de dire quand
j'essaie parfois de résumer mon projet
j'ai envie de dire surtout en période de
crise mais ce qu'il faut c'est montrer
que le théâtre c'est absolument
indispensable il avait la culture c'est
pas ça pas inutile c'est ça questionné
par un supplice ce n'est pas qu'un
supplément d'âme c'est vraiment au
fondement de de notre société voire de
notre civilisation et je pensais et vous
avez raison de dire que c'est souvent
les les auteurs par les créateurs qui
pose les vrais problèmes sur l'évolution
des sociétés alors ça c'est le premier
le premier mot c'était contemporain il
ya ya ya aussi les le jeune public puis
qui est temps d'ouvrir une mention
important on est on est dans une rame à
sion dont parlait des marionnettes
vallée du tir c'est vrai que c'est
important alors le cirque et la
marionnette les environs mais
traditionnelle un bon lit et en tout cas
beaucoup bien sûr le jeune public c'est
très important on est dans un territoire
saint quentin en yvelines en général
guyancourt en particulier où il ya
beaucoup de jeunes donc forcément on
s'adresse on s'adresse à ce public qui
représente un vivier très important donc
je dirais que c'est à peu près la moitié
des spectacles un qui sont tournés vers
le jeune public parfois dès l'âge de 6
mois ou un an et l'union fait on fait
parfois pour les tout petits dans des
dents des toutes petites jauges et sont
des spectacles très agréables souvent il
ya des liens avec les
les écoles des collèges c'est important
et ça fait partie du projet aux
municipales de guillon rain et qui est
inscrit vraiment dès le départ dans le
projet de vie un poète qui était menacé
un enseignant donc le poète était
enseignant aussi le poète était en
réunion et oui le maire de guyancourt a
été directeur des grilles maternelle
donc l'éducation l'enfance c'est une
part très importante du projet municipal
et c'est ce qui fait que chaque enfant
scolarisé dans la ville de guyancourt
est invité une fois par an avec sa
classe à découvrir un spectacle et bien
souvent ils viennent moyennant 3 euros
au revoir un deuxième par voix un
troisième donc ça représente vraiment un
vivier important et c'est aussi ça qui
nous permet d'être de devenir d'inscrits
la ferme de belgrade dans un processus
de création jeune public parce que comme
on a beaucoup d'enfants qui viennent du
coup ça vaut le coup d'installer des
équipes qui viennent travailler qui
répète parfois deux semaines parce
qu'ensuite on fait des séries donc on a
la possibilité de jouer les joueurs
sommes souvent huit fois l'actuel forme
habituelle ses huit fois donc si
scolaire et parfois sur des toutes
petites formes voilà je parlais des
jeunes enfants donc en les envoyant deux
ans trois ans on évite de les amasser en
grand nombre dans la za alors là donc
c'est souvent ils sont parfois une
classe b voire trois classes et donc ça
fait des séries de 14 ou 18
représentations donc ça permet au
spectacle vraiment de se développer vrai
alors troisième mot qui est important
d'abord encore prononcé mais c'est la
parité oui c'est à dire que vous a
essayé d'avoir autant de créations
faites par des femmes que fait par des
hommes ce qui n'est pas le cas
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
hein on en parle et on a enregistré mais
ce qui est pas le cas de la culture en
général bah oui on pourrait s'attendre à
ce que la culture le théâtre échappe un
peu aux règles du sexisme ordinaire
c'est pas vrai non les chiffres sont
difficiles à avouer on est donc dans les
théâtres qui ont un label nationaux 85%
des textes sont écrits par les hommes
voilà alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui oui
alors évidemment un théâtre qui sera
plus sur le répertoire
le répète noir alors que des femmes
écrivains des femmes écrivait dès les
16e et 17e siècles mais on n'a pas
tellement voulu le retenir il en existe
1 l'année prochaine on aura
vraisemblablement une création de madame
de villedieu un pays pièce écrite au
xviie siècle et qui a été mise en scène
par molière lui même en 1665 donc
molière montait notre défense ont dix
maunoury ce que le terme
étymologiquement le plus correct même si
il froisse un peu certaines oreilles
n'ont donc là vous être 50 voilà on a
voulu être à l'image d'un miroir mais
quand il ya 85 % des cris fait par les
hommes est ce qu'on trouve facilement
des autres femmes oui dans le théâtre
contemporain oui je dirais il ya
vraiment un renouvellement et c'est une
chance parce que se tourner aussi vers
vers ses programmations paritaire donner
la parole aux femmes qu'elles soient à
l'écriture ou à la mise en scène sait
aussi sortir un peu des sentiers battus
et offrir au public une vraie diversité
à laquelle voilà c'est pas toujours été
le cas moi j'ai l'impression et c'est un
renouveau les femmes n'écrivent pas tout
à fait de la même manière que les hommes
l'idée de dire qu'elles sont égales ne
veut pas dire qu'elles sont identiques
évidemment et donc ça apporte un autre
regard un théâtre très intéressant il ya
beaucoup d'autres is de très grande
qualité aujourd'hui alors un dernier mot
pour conclure parce que malheureusement
le temps ou presque il ya beaucoup
d'offres culturelles quand même sur le
territoire de 50 ans
comment on arrive à faire vivre voilà la
ferme de bel ébat par rapport à la scène
nationale par beaucoup de pertes qui
existe dans le territoire bottes toute
l'idée et c'est l'idée de la communauté
d'agglomération je crois c'est de miser
sur comment dire l'émulation on est on
est on essaye en tout cas autant que
faire ce peut être plus partenaires que
concurrents donc on travaille on
travaille souvent ensemble illzach mais
il arrive qu'on ait des spectacles
programmés la scène nationale avec la
ferme de bel ébat la ligne de mêlée bas
avec le prisme voilà on aura le bal des
intouchables qui regroupe beaucoup de
structures de la communauté
d'agglomération on travaille ensemble on
se fait forcément un peu concurrence
parfois vous avez chacun vos
spécificités et voilà notamment les les
trois points qu'on ya déjà des
dominantes cherche à chaque lieu cultive
un petit peu sa spécificité ce qui
permet au public de ne donner vie gay
parmi nous merci infiniment là aussi
avoir pour pouvoir la programmation peut
se procurer le petit fascicule qui
incite seulement il ya le site de la
ferme de bel ébat et il ya ces nouveaux
le site de vente en ligne la plate forme
commune à tous les théâtres de la
communauté d'agglomération sur le
kiosque merci infiniment merci à vous